stravaccato sulla sedia scillato come
pochi che gioca potrà mai essere ma
proprio della indigo vice di riprovare
sempre isaac ma per il fatto che
comunque il rollo ecco il fatto delle
non posso trovare oggetti nuovi più easy
quindi o usare proprio sempre alta
questo periodo almeno finché siamo
all'inizio per scoprire un po di 99 va
bene ma va no guarda è già una stanza in
credito o per iniziato già stato
impossibile vabbè che culo da rischiata
e lo rischiata almeno andiamo subito
sulla 3g è la madonna quanta roba ho
trovato fantastico mag
no ce l'ha sacri file madonna no fermi
pazzesco c'è praticamente questi ti non
ti fanno danno ma ti tolgono le labbra
energia all'oggetto pazzesco che nemico
pazzesco che alle volte c'è adesso in
questo caso è ottimo però alle volte può
essere bastarda come cosa perché alle
volte la carica dell'oggetto più
importante della tua stessa vita
e non sto scherzando c'è veramente
incredibile adesso è andata ancora bene
va bene with all aja porca vacca e vabbè
se colpiscono intanto qualcosa mi fa
mela me li fa diventare amici non ho
capito sta roba
ma perché perché mi diventa amica si
ceylon blacks che fa sta roba
non so perché strano cosa mi dà bello lo
uso
psp shop sfida va benissimo non avrei
mollato niente allora andiamo lì qua
ragazzi sempre le parti nuove sempre le
parti nuove perché sono molto più
difficili però almeno vedo io vedo le
cose nuove non so che teoricamente
dovrei vincere però mi interessa vedere
le cose noi quindi per adesso che altro
solo qua devo ricordarmi però che mi
serve sempre una chiave in più perché
per entrare mi serve una chiave però poi
mi serve anche per per la 3 giu in
questo caso adesso non c'ero porco
demonio li vediamo di crohn a chiave
eccola per culo del iv
allora ragazzi del iv è uno degli
oggetti più rari del gioco è
potenzialmente un oggetto pazzesco
perché fa questo guardate del iv
denominata si chiama junior ed elite
vedrete fa questo tu stai fermo e
diventi così quando sei così 6 immortale
però non puoi fare niente non puoi
attaccare s'attacchi ti toglie
l'immortalità dell'attrice cosa serve se
non puoi attaccare come luci nemici se
tu hai i minion che ti fa danno ai
nemici
hai vinto perché presidente fa tutto lui
lasci che faccia tutto lui quindi la del
drift leaf come grassi dice è ottima
non so se nei secchi c'è qualcosa nel
dubbio le metto qui c'è un nemico ottimo
diamo al boss direttamente ragazzi
un'ottica che c'è un nemico o cielo
fosse chi mano pezzo di culo prendi se
kimi rilancia sto pezzente maledetto che
io presi la chiave me la tengo perché se
non riesco ad aprire la porta dopo ok a
wall mount questo qua è difficilissimo
lo trovate l'altra volta mi è andata
bene solo perché avevo la fiamma blake
baggett fa un danno ce la fanno più di
lo stesso danno ma nel senso edifici da
schivare porca [ __ ] è uno di quei di
quelle sanguisughe è formato extralarge
e orribile
yes no questa è la merda questo è buono
decisamente meglio del sap c'è un sacco
di tears sparo velocissimo vi servono
due bombe per entrare nella stanza
quella di fianco rega non so sente la c
o meno
ok qua c'è l'altra bomba maschile mentre
noi va bene abbiamo aumentato ed years
che adesso sono praticamente al massimo
cioè non al massimo ma quasi mysteries
paper fifa non solo non solo la faccia
sinceramente provo 1 i dossi
ciao
andiamo nelle miniere ragazzi ormai le
miniere sono a casa nostra qua cioè è
vietato minecraft sempre più difficile
tra l'altro però dove altro che schifo
tanti occhi ciò questo lira aveva tanto
di vento e tipo invisibile non capisco
che cacchione let's be nice
per un'altra porta i pochi rossi questi
qua fa normale boia a devo farli fuori
anche quando muoiono e sono nate ok i
fuochi rossi sempre da far fuori i
ragazzi che ti fregano come niente non
ho più visto le segrete ma chissene
l'hack è male che è successo a sono
bombe volanti ottimo buono a sapersi
io dovrei avventarmi il danno perchè
così fanno più danno anche i ragni e
dovrei avere un altro mineo ma
assolutamente o si un cuore grazie a dio
meno male alla cena tinte ed abbiamo
visto buon rock night smo rock e ragazzi
ti fanno la pipì lento maticamente al
danno non male quindi se aumenta un po
la velocità siamo a cavallo oa metà
almeno danno adesso che ha aumentato
mini sfrutto meglio i ragnetti allora
qua dentro
no che schifo allora qua devo prendere
st bombe tirargli la sopra
ok va bene ma quindi posso anche
sfruttarla per lanciarla sul muro si che
poi non c'è niente prove
che figata sta cosa comunque delle bombe
rosse ragazzi va bene
regoliamo vediamo cosa c'è il dente non
è male
ogni tanto mi spara un dea no
siamo nel nostro foto una cazzata ho
detto niente gretzky dehon gretzky dehon
non so chi sia
che cacchio è un ragazzi non ha una vita
non ha una vita lega cosa vuol dire come
lo batto questo ad e andate a demo
battere all ondate tipo e tipo la grid
minchia che mostrano va ad ondate quindi
e poi e poi lo sconfitto automaticamente
o devo battere pure lui mi chiedi e
bruttissimo cioè difficile
madonna no ragazzi assurdo questo va
presa i nemici e bellissima sta roba è
veramente figo il mio dominion quale
nuovo raga non c'era prima è fighissimo
ti frizza proprio il nemico e quando lo
colpisci farfa questa cosa
bellissimo e anche sarà utile perché fa
danno non ho merda l'hack è male per
doverlo il cuore futuro certo sicuro al
cuore
merda per botta che l'ho perso 5 nonno
questo che poi da battere anche lui
perché già è difficile così di
figuriamoci
penso che poi sia morto perché proprio
già difficile questa la 6 su 6
adesso avendo già una difficoltà il
suprema
l'hacker male porca put ansa e morto
minchia raga che casino mi ha dato un
oggetto di merda due ore presto schifo
dai allora raga questa non ce l'ho
non so cos'è non c'è neanche nella
nell'app queens è fortissimo
praticamente ogni tot che ammazzi gente
ti spa una un minion vediamo
eccolo lì veniva stonato mio è veramente
forte sta roba semi spa ex guardanti
minimo suonato mariah pazzesco veramente
assurdo non è mamma però afferma non è
mamma che cazzo devo fare qua aiuto a
lanciare stai bond ok però non li faccio
da ma se no stavo con le bombe merda
a [ __ ] meno male che a principi e bar o
schivato tutto ci sono quelli che sono i
boss che di poi far danno solo con le
cose che trovi in giro a li togli la
corazza polita dal normale perché prego
meno male ci sono i minion guarda mi
fanno danno pazzesco quello è all stat
up ma tutte le stata apma tele shuffle a
è un casino ma vero che lo prendo
sono stata upson staff di papà troppi
danno mi muovo lentissimo però molto più
danno boh secondo me non è male satana
vediamo cosa certo non mi ricordo cosa
sono americano cosa fanno uno ti fa
volare che questo che l'altro non mi
cosa fa tipo dei mash up per i cori
quanto vediamo fa questo ragazzo
porca [ __ ] non funziona non so se serve
però io lo faccio lo uso aspetta fa
questa cosa varati nei cuori
tutti ti toglie tutti quelli matita
tutti con i neri e che aumenta il danno
che a mente un po la speed
diciamo che è abbastanza utile per come
stavo messo adesso però comunque il
fatto di non avere più con i normali
pesa no man mano che palle le manone di
mamma che mi schiacciano dei chi cacchio
a un minion sto male ma lei che cacchio
di disastro è veramente forte però sono
tutti i minion che non sparano da soli e
quindi non posso usare ancora
la leaf che sarebbe questo ancora non
posso se ne trova uno che farà la trova
e finita completamente una roba positiva
io posso avere questa su di sfiga
perenne ma posso apro questo che merda
mi ricordo cosa fa ah ok ok praticamente
spalle teoricamente spara da solo se sta
vicino ai nemici spara da solo con
joinet ho trovato è praticamente fuori
alle vere minion sbloccato la la con
gioia che questa questo è questa
evoluzione quindi questo dovrebbe stare
da sola e vediamo se funziona test
chiesto fermo sono fermo quindi non mi
può fare danno a nessuno e lui fa danno
a tutti hai visto è fortissima del iv b
prima che adesso se non mi avvicino
quello non lo fa nessuno fuori
ok ma esse possono uccidere anni non
sono uscite poco bene allora sono messo
abbastanza bene ragazzi mamma fermate
fai tu io non faccio niente volete che
succede che proprio lui
bene è stata è stata presa io sono molto
affaticato allora e non so se devo
andare di sopra ogni sotto per il
semplice fatto che non so che con non so
i boss nuovi cosa sono non so quali sono
i quali siano i boss nuovi quindi non so
se andare sopra sotto del casinò non
vado sopra di sopra ok
let's go va bene perché non ho ben
capito se effettivamente tutti i nuovi
boss li trovi solo nelle porte vicine
oppure se ti trovi anche cos'è qua sono
cioè tutto c'è c'è anche una hanno messo
liquido amniotico nell'uomo
va bene per rendere tutto un po più
veritiero va bene ho capito è un po
strana come cosa prova ci sta ha senso
scientificamente
tutto si muove come se fossimo
e ancora nella placenta nice ragazzi e
sto bene sto sbattendo del fatto che
posso stare ferma perché sono è tutto un
gameplay monotono però potrete stare
fermo ad ogni istanza sostanzialmente
chissenefrega
sarebbe un gameplay che dura 80 anni
però almeno arrivo alla fine questo
sicuro e comunque change my mind ma
l'uomo a parte quando li colpiscono che
mi levano un anno in più è molto più
semplice del tutte le stanze che nuove
nel dlc nuovo quando avrò proprio un
cuore rimango proprio fermo nella serie
non mi deve succedere niente
ok vediamo poto lievo note flotte
orribile del note orribile ragazzi ho
sempre odiato anche perché li devo
rimanere dietro solamente a danno
veramente è uno di quelli che oggi di
più perché fa danno sempre ok ora
logica vorrebbe che io stessi fermo ogni
volta che succede qualcosa perché sto
morendo sostanzialmente una che nuvolari
capì cosa fa eterna life quando muoio
posso risposto la possibilità di
rispondere non è male non è male
questo vado sotto però dei turisti
afferma ogni istanza sostanzialmente per
essere sicuri non prender danno perché
sono muoio però vabbè è un po e un po
too much
non ho voglia di stare ferme al massimo
muoio ragazzi cazzi cioè stare fermi per
non prendere da me per quella euro in
quanto io adesso lo sapevo eternal no
non ha funzionato il collare di carpi
peccato comunque era era veramente una
bella ram peccato che hanno buttata così
signori spero che vi sia piaciuto questa
di panico baisakhi oggi cose tra matera
e mi piace anche questo cerco io data
descrizione so se ci si chiede allora
seguito della ragazza
[Musica]